[Music]
hey guys
and welcome to another episode of
congratulations
[Music]
we are here today gathered in this cult
to share ideas
and we need to be sharing ideas and we
need to be uh
showing our friends this podcast because
how's it cult gonna grow if a cult
doesn't grow speaking of which the cult
merch is up live on chrisley.com i
didn't mean for my hair to look this
[__] [__] in today but that's why so
i guess subconsciously i didn't even put
this on i didn't mean to i didn't mean
to not put this on but your boy looks
crazy [__] feathery doesn't he
anyway
um
yeah it looks crazy feathery but also
chrisley.com for the new merch and also
we just came out with these i had this
uh my uh button the oops button
on my desk for a bit i hit it a few
times and you guys uh were like could
this come out so
we brought it out dude and now and now
when you're you get this on your [__]
desk and when somebody sits there and
then and this is some boss [__] to have
though for real if you're a boss if
you're a ceo
and somebody comes in and they're not
doing their job and you go so tell me
about what happened today and they say
well you know i had all the uh the uh
transparencies and we tried to put them
together and we tried to file everything
and i couldn't get it out quick enough
and you just go boops you just hit that
dude and then you say you're fired so
these are on sale chrisleya.com
um and uh we're gonna be do i mean these
jesus i don't even know
that's my favorite dude
wow i am
obnoxious dude but this can't be
obnoxious dude this cult is obnoxious
um
this code is obnoxious
oh oh no it's so obnoxious that's well
how has that not been a jay-z lyric
i'm so obnoxious
okay
um i'll be in grand prairie texas and
that's dallas
on august 26th i'll be in wichita kansas
home of the b b btk killer august 27th
atlanta georgia september 9th washington
d.c
september 10th
september 23rd stockton and oakland
september 24th peoria
october 7th rockford illinois
october 8th raleigh north carolina home
of the staircase guy who threw his wife
down the staircase maybe
uh october 24th
first
october 20 colin firth
october 22nd savannah georgia denver
colorado november 5th and then november
6th cheyenne wyoming but guess what dude
november 12th
oh [__] we did one at the wang theater
and then
wasn't enough so we added another
november 12th november 12th two shows at
the wang theater in boston albany at the
egg lakeland florida jacksonville
florida these are just dates coming up
so go get your tickets at crystalia.com
and uh i'm sorry my hair is crazy
feathery
whoops i'm sorry my my hair's crazy
i'll wash my hair today and i always
forget when i wash my hair how [__]
fantastic the feathery hair be
i always forget but i do it and then i
let it dry a bit if i'm not in a rush
that's the best i let it set i said it
and then forget it
and then i take a little bit of pomade i
put it in my hair and then your boy
looks real feathery when he's walking
around the town right
i went to get my iced americana with the
purple straw matching the balenciaga oh
he's so monochromatic it's obnoxious
oh dude he's so monochromatic it's like
he's oh he's so monochrome chromatic
it's obnoxious
oh it looks like he got in a fight with
a m with a bunch of moss but he stays
monochromatic oh god the ring matches
the rolly what the heck
oh my god dude
everything that sparkles is the same and
all the [__] in cloth and threads is
purple what the [__]
and he's got a plastic straw that
happens to match his shirt
he's obnoxious i'm so obnoxious
dude so that's what's up man
so uh but you know that's what it is we
share ideas in this code and one of the
ideas is keeping it monochromatic that's
what we do so uh it's all good
um and uh yeah he wore the balenciaga
dripped out on stage the other day and
he had to work for the podcast dude
so
it's crazy that they make this shirt and
then they [__] literally just
snip it and then sell it for more so
it's all good i need to be snipping more
on my shirts dude honestly i need to be
taking all my shirts and just making
carefully placed [__] holes in all of
them and selling them for 100 a little
bit more dude i should come out with
merch
that's cut like that dude that's the
[__] man what the [__] have i been doing
my son play hits this all the time
where's the oops button where's the oop
so i don't play oops button
um
so we did it and now we got the oops
button and it's for sale but uh yeah
dude and all the funds go directly to me
because bags and all the funds go
directly to my pockets because i'm
trying to get them lunked up like a
bunch of beetles and it's fine
um
but uh so yeah
i had a good time this week did some
shows did a lot of crowd work i got some
crowd work clips coming go subscribe to
the clips channel not the clips channel
sorry the crystallia channel on youtube
uh most of you are subscribed to this
channel but i have the other channel
that is subscribed and you can just go
to the channels we i told one fire to do
it did you do it yet he did it he didn't
do it it was an insecure nod like this
didn't do it yet will be done by the
time this podcast comes out go to my
channels and click on that um
and uh
so yeah i got some crowd work clips
coming out dude and i've been working
the act and you know i'm going on tour
to do this pretty soon i'll film
something and who knows where i'll drop
it i mean maybe i'll drop it on youtube
maybe i'll drop it on a [__] platform
who knows or you know what maybe a boy
will just have it on bhs and just hand
it out after shows because that's how
raw
and rugged he is dude you see the shirt
did he get in the [__] fight with a
bunch of moths you see the shirt
did edward scissorhands
what did he try to was he practicing
and chris was one of the fir before he
had his cut lice you know what i'm
saying like
um
so yeah i've been having a good time on
stage you know some days are good some
days are bad really been battling uh
some depression and my ocd but it's all
good we push forward we keep moving you
know i took my son to uh pop hop in
gambie's house that's grandma and
grandpa for those of you that don't know
but my dad wants to be called pop-pop
and my mom wants a pick called gammy um
they're both insane but um i drove him
to uh my to their to grandma's house and
grandma's grandma grandpa's house and
when we went there
um he he was like i am so excited to see
pop-pop and gamey and melted my heart
and then afterwards
dude um
we ate chinese food and then he ate a
lot of chicken he wanted chicken so he
ate chicken and then
they were like do you want to give him
some dessert and i said no because i had
a [__] idea dude that i was going to
get ice cream with the boy now let me
tell you something about getting ice
cream with the boy now it was just
father's son that day okay a lot of
times kristin comes with us but you know
she had some stuff to do so it just went
just
dad and son dude i had a a dad a father
on sunday which is crazy to think that
i'm a father still you know it's crazy
to think that i'm a father even still
that's been two two in two years plus
um
but uh i took my son to get some ice
cream
and i was in line
getting ice cream and it was uh
i was waiting and he was so excited and
i was like what kind do you want and i
said chocolate and he said yes and i
said or vanilla and he said yes so i'm
like okay i guess it's up to me so i got
him vanilla and i got him in a cone and
he sat there and ate it and i was eating
it with them and i didn't even want ice
cream but i was eating a little bit it
was like the cinnamon snickerdoodle kind
it was really nice it was salt and straw
just absolutely [__] gorgeous in my
mouth dude i mean dude it [__] was i
put it in my mouth and it was just
dancing around it was so beautiful
dancing around playing nice with the
taste buds but my god it was gorgeous
dude i mean i put that [__]
snickerdoodle cinnamon style in my mouth
with the spoon and [__] it was
gorgeous dude i meant it it [__]
might as well have been [__] colin
feral sex tape because it was [__]
gorgeous
ah it was so gorgeous the snickerdoodle
cinnamon in your mouth is gorgeous
so i ate it and my son was licking it
and i said why don't you bite it and he
said no dust yik and he would lick it
and dude i was sitting there and i took
some pictures you know i looked like a
dorky dad whatever i was wearing the
[__] full purple life rip suit i
looked like a [__] jackass but that's
just how i i you know
that's just how i [__] that's how i
rolled right that day and i didn't want
to change for nobody
and i brought my son to um
get ice cream and he was eating it dude
and i was thinking about like how cool
it was to be a kid right like a lot of
the times when you have a kid you think
about like oh you get to realize people
say like oh you get to relive the
moments from your childhood just in a
different way and you get to experience
it via your kid and how amazing that is
and that is amazing but i actually on
the drive home
thought about like something that i
don't know
i think i think about this less than
that first thing i just said but the
fact that i
got to have ice cream with my son
is such a
it's such a great i'm so lucky for that
i'm so lucky that i was able to
experience taking
my loved one to ice cream
and giving that to him and watching the
joy on his face that is so beautiful for
me to experience now i usually think you
know because look i'm a self i've been a
selfish guy in my life and this is a
very selfish thought thinking about how
how you know i'm it's not selfish it's
grateful i'll say it's grateful it's not
like i'm like [__] yeah this is awesome
i get to it's not like [__] going and
getting a [__] you know
a bj or some [__] it's not like going
and getting some [__] pizza where
everything's just gorgeous in your mouth
you know i was doing it because i'm
grateful to i was thinking
i'm grateful i get to experience this
but anyway what i've what i'm trying to
say is i used i i have lived selfishly
right like in my life before and i'm
still selfish sometimes but i try to
keep that in check and i try to be
grateful and do
more things for other people and live
like that but my point is when it comes
to my son all that [__] kind of goes out
the window and i just want him to be
happy so i'm mostly thinking of oh i
want him to have ice cream because i
want him to be happy oh i want him to go
to the park because i want him to be
happy but i actually got to sit in the
gratefulness of it in the oh wow i get
to experience this i'm so lucky that not
everybody gets to experience this
look it's a very common thing taking
your son to ice cream but i think the
sitting and and actually realizing
what's happening in your life and how
great of a moment this is
is is is not something that i'm always
thinking of and i got to
sit and take that in in that moment and
i don't think i'm ever going to forget
that dude i was sitting outside i took
some pictures and it was beautiful and
it was just licking the ice cream and
then
and that's it and that's it dude it's
not even really a story to tell it's
just a [__] check-in with you guys
about how grateful i am for moments like
that you know
i think we get so uh
uh
consumed with oh am i gonna like this is
he gonna like this is she gonna like
this are they gonna like this or am i
accepted but i just the moment was
beautiful dude and i'm so happy
i was so happy for that moment dude um
and that's it and that was a little bit
more dramatic than i thought it would be
but whatever it doesn't matter life
keeps on ripping dude life keeps on
ripping dude you lick that ice cream and
life keeps on
um
it keeps on ripping gorgeous
so yeah
there's a lot of [__] uh i don't know
what this is dude this was hilarious and
i can play this on um
my phone because i don't have it on i
can't play it on my computer but what's
up with the fake accounts pretending
that they're celebrities i don't know if
this happened i think well i know this
happens to who was i talking to it
happened to
uh somebody's telling me it happened to
morgan uh wallin um waylon wallin i
don't know and uh and um
but like
there are so many accounts that reach
out to people either pretending they're
me or pretending that they are
uh an assistant of mine like they'll go
like this is a
something that they'll write like here
let me look i i just can't believe that
like
here um
do i even have it or did i [__] throw
it away
um
[Music]
it's it i [__] don't even know if i
have it anymore but they say [__] like
um
hey uh crystalia really appreciates you
so much and he just wants you to know
that and you know uh um he's such a
you're a he's so grateful for you and
um you should write him
which is so [__] weird like what is
the end game for this bot or person some
of these are profiles that look real
what's the end game they're gonna say
okay and then write me
and then what
i'm gonna ignore it
the person is doing things that don't
matter
but there's one i think this guy's
trying to get some money out of this
person
and
dude this was so great so this guy is
trying to get some i think money out of
this person i don't know what it is but
he put his account was christ delia
spelled it wrong
gonna go to hell christ delia dude and
he's writing people as me a lot of times
people will do chris dalia but like
something will be a little bit different
like with two l's or whatever so this
guy uh so this person reached out to me
and this was so [__] funny dude this
person wrote this so christ delia writes
to this person i was scrolling on my fan
page when i came across your sensible
profile your profile looks really nice
and sensible too so i decided to add you
here on my private page so we can
communicate
communicate i think i mean thanks for
being a great fan to me
dude
here's a word i never say
sensible
i don't say it it's definitely not in
the lexicon of crystalline's vocabulary
i definitely don't say it twice
i definitely don't say it twice in one
message okay
also thanks for being such a great fan
to me safari so the guy there's a bunch
of red flags right there are so many red
flags
so then this
then he sends a picture of what looks
like
me i actually i remember this picture
was when i was in australia
and it looks like i'm taking a selfie
because i was doing a video i took a
screenshot and sent it to this person
and this person wrote can you send me an
auto message saying hi to me it would
mean the world
auto message and then she says my name
is hannah as you can see on my profile
if you could say hi to me so the guy
does
and this is what he sends dude
[Applause]
didn't even try
arabic
i can
hey dude you can say h
cause you said hannah so say hi
not
i can
the sequel to irobot
[Laughter]
the prequel
from the makers of irobot comes
i can
[Laughter]
dude the mo the most sensible movie this
year
dude how could it be real how could they
go
[Laughter]
so sensible
i am
dude who are these [__] people what
are we trying to get
so not uh uh so not gonna be me that's
on my instagram if you wanna go see it
it's [__] hilarious go to my
instagram
and uh dude let's play it again
i can't even
these [__] jerk-offs
like they think you know they think
they're gonna what are they gonna get
forty dollars out of somebody
i cannot oh she's gonna be like what's
your cash app
[Laughter]
also
the best part was
the girl's name wasn't hannah
no [__] it was not hannah
the name was not
she said her name was hannah but on the
[__] her act
but her but on the profile it's not
there
it's not that it's like anastasia or
something
dude doing
the bare minimum
unbelievable dude i fell out when that
happened i was done i was it that was it
dude how funny is that
why are there so many fake accounts
pretending that they're me why are there
so many fake accounts pretending that
there's anyone who does that
it i if you're a bot okay but first of
all why to get money okay besides that
why
it's not everyone's not trying to get
the money
some people are doing it for different
reasons i want to know why
um
so anyway dude
i mean so funny dude um
i was at the uh i'm getting sinus
surgery you know so i'm gonna do that
soon i can't take [__] uh
i'll probably actually the next episode
of lifeline or congratulations i'm going
to be having a [__] thing over my
nose but i'm i might get a [__] nose
job dude just a straight up beautiful
one a really big beautiful one dude
there was a guy that walked by me the
other day and he had a re i love dudes
with big noses and i don't mean crooked
ass big noses i mean a nice big nose is
a manly is a very manly [__] cool
like sexy thing for a man and i'll go
one further i like big noses on women
i do i like a strong nose on a woman
i like a strong nose on a woman and i'm
not lying dude when i see a strong nose
on a woman i think that that's sexy when
a girl's got a bodacious nose that's
insane to me dude i go like this
hold a second dude that's the kind of
guy i am dude guys watch [__] titties
guys watch titties when they bounce you
know when a girl and she does the
downstep and the [__] tits go up and
they're walking like this right and
they're walking like this on the down
step to the right the titties go up to
the left and then down step to the left
the titties go up to the right guys like
bodacious titties your boy loves
bodacious noses dude i like a strongly
amnesia nose on a woman that's what i
like i like a [__] strong looks like
i got bonked in the head when i was
eight years old and it grew to a little
bit of a bigger nose than it would have
normally if i didn't get bonked in the
head type a nose on a woman that's what
i like dude right some guys are asked
guys some guys are titty guys no of
course all guys are asking titty guys
like when somebody says are you an
astrotis guy you're just like what i'm a
guy give me both bodacious but i'll go
one further i like a nose i'm a nose
girl okay
he's a nose girl
um
so i like a nose
girl so i might just [__] around and get
a bigger nose dude i mean the guy my
doctor told me and he does all the
[__] you know he does all the celebs
so i'm [__] back baby
dude he does all the celebs dude
talked to nyle horan had the same
surgery i'm gonna get i'm [__] back
[__] yeah dude two of the guys from
nickelback got the same surgery i got i
saw the plaque in the office i'm [__]
back baby
and let's not forget about chris
daughtry i'm back baby
dude i'm sitting in walls with [__]
platinum plaques i'm like did you do all
these guys noses and he said yep
sometimes i do their throats [__] yeah
do to your nose and throat doctor just
clumping them all together that's
probably the worst doctor just kind of
clumping all the shits together right
you know like the knee doctors are like
we specialize in the knee because we
know all about the knee you got all the
leftover [__]
so i was like what if i got a nose job
just [__] shoot you know shooting the
[__] and he says three times as painful
three times the recovery and i go god
damn dude i'll probably just stick to
the wall inside my sinuses
um so he's gonna break it and then
[__] fix it but i was sitting there
oh god and you know you have to do so
many pre-op shits man pre-op it's like
one of those things you know you got to
do pre-op because like
they got to make sure everything's fine
but like everything's fine you know
because i'm a 42 year old [__] spry
male like i'm just like you know i'm
built like a [__] brick [__] house
you know i'm six too and the [__] the
way fabric just falls off my shoulder
it's like i don't even you can't even
see my midsection you know a lot of guys
have [__] a lot of guys have like
tubs around their [__] like that tire
not me dude my [__] my shoulders are so
broad you can't even tell i'm veed out
but if you want to lift up this shirt
for a surprise
right
lift up this shirt for a surprise i'm
veed out and you better hope i have
pants on because if i don't somebody's
gonna trip
so um
whoa careful where you're walking that's
my penis
so um
so yeah so anyway you got to do all the
pre-op shits so i'm doing the pre-op
shits and i got to go in to do the
[__] pre-op with diff and they're
always like you know i've done one
surgery before that i had to be put out
for i'm always the guy who's like leave
me awake if you can leave me awake leave
me awake
leave me awake they're like we got to
take your [__]
wisdom teeth out i say leave me awake oh
are you sure most people leave me awake
dude
what are you talking about man
what are you talking about what is this
i've seen kings of pain i want to be
like that you know i'm not going under
for some [__] some adults in my mouth
[__] it
[__] it put them all in my mouth i want
to whip you think i want you
tooling around in my mouth you think i
want you
tooling around in what's pink
you think i want you tooling around
in
[__]
in what's pink while i'm getting some
shut-eye dude hey tell the
anesthesiologist take a [__] hike hey
anesthesiologist here's your best with a
bunch of pockets on it go enjoy some
sunshine
are you kidding me
so um i went to go get the [__] kid
get the hair right in the thing see this
is what happens when i'm real feathery
dude can't get the hair right in the
thing in the under the thing where is it
i can never tell what's right or what's
left so um
so yeah so i'm like uh so i got to get
put under for this because it's my nose
and he's gonna break it and then [__]
align the sinuses break it in the line
of sinuses so um
so i'm gonna do that and so i had to go
get a pre-op [__] and uh while i was
getting the pre-op stuff i had to go to
another doctor there to do the pre-op
and then
that doctor was like you know i'm gonna
get you i'm gonna get you in ekg i'm
gonna take your blood and i'm gonna feel
your abdomen and then you should be fine
and then so
i do it
and then she's like i'll call you monday
for the results didn't didn't call me
just texted me a link but guess who
doesn't click on links baby
guess who doesn't click on links no
matter what it looked oh it looked real
it looked legit and also nobody knew i
went to this doctor but guess who
doesn't click on links baby that's me
dude you think i'm gonna click on a link
and then all of a sudden somebody in
dubai is gonna [__] i'm on the hook
for [__] 45k
um no way dude so i didn't click the
link so hopefully i'm fine but i'm gonna
go into that
so anyway i'm at the the thing and she's
like we want to get you uh
has has he done a chest x-ray on you and
i'm like i don't think so you know he
did a jaw a mou a [__] what's pink
x-ray on me and she was like okay i'm
going to have you go to the chest x-ray
people and this is why like i don't like
you know when you're in the doctor's and
you wait and you're there like before
it's 2 30 you go there's 2 30 and then
they you don't get seen till like 3 15
and it's like then don't have a point
because here's the thing she was just
like just walk over there they'll take
you and i'm like well then what the [__]
are we doing with these appointments i'm
always waiting for one minute and then i
realize when i get there dude it's
because of guys like me
because i'm walking in on the side and i
got to [__] they need to be better at
it is what i'm saying
i walked over there there were like
eight people in line with appointments
and they're like we'll get to you and
now i felt bad
so i'm there
and i'm waiting to do it and everyone's
[__] really nice you know because
they should be by the way because you're
going under the knife i didn't do it yet
but i know i have to so
and then she said that the the person
behind the the desk was like
uh mr dalia can you come here
i need to ask you something and i walked
over and i was like what the [__] like
it has to be in private because you know
medical stuff is real dicey so i walk up
and she's like what is it dude of your
surgery and i and i told her which i
don't even know why i said i don't even
tell you guys i don't know why it's a
secret but like i feel like it's a
secret i can't tell people and then i
told her and then she was like okay
thanks so long and then [__] went
back and i sat down dude and i'm gonna
send you a picture of this okay i'm
gonna send you a picture of this
because i took a picture of this because
when it happened i needed to document it
okay i needed to document it
because i wanted to and i did it for the
podcast all right and i also texted
friends about this
now i've told you stories like this
before but it happened again and it
happens to me more than anybody and i
don't know why it might be because i'm a
spry tall drink of water it might be
because i sit down like bon jovi it
might be because i [__] relax like a
praying mantis but i'm chilling right
and i'm waiting and i'm waiting too long
and i want to relax so what do i do i
make it my home dude when i want to
relax and when things are taking too
long i make [__] my home and sometimes i
sit badly and by badly i mean good okay
that's what i mean because if you're
sitting the way you want to you're being
you and you know what if you're being
you you're welcome hey everyone around
me you're welcome you get the real me my
walls are down and this is what you get
congratulations all right and i like
when people are the real them because i
don't want any [__] secrets if
somebody's snooping around not being
themselves then what happens i don't
know who i'm dealing with and i can get
stabbed in the back
okay
so i'm sitting you like one time when i
was younger i was trying to get financed
for this movie i was trying to produce
and i sat down on the couch and i sat
down real relaxed and afterwards my
producing partner said yo i don't know
if you should sit like that and i said
why he said because it's kind of
disrespectful and i'm like no it's not
i'm just chilling and like yeah but we
wanted money from those people and i'm
like yeah but you know i don't think it
matters that much and then later on like
a year later he said you know i want to
apologize for that day i said you
shouldn't sit like that i actually found
i was reading this thing uh in some
[__] book that if you have the balls
to sit the way you want and not
respectful then people feel like they
need you and that probably helped us get
the funding for a movie because guess
what we did get the funding for the
[__] movie dude
anyway
that's neither here nor there because
now i'm here at this [__] post-op
chest x-ray thing
and i do the [__] bon jovi right i
put my foot up and i don't put it on a
chair i put it on a
uh i'll put the picture up right here
but i put it on the
for those of you listening i put it on
the armrest of the chair and by the way
the arm when i say arm rest it's very
light it's a very light armrest it's
it's like a [__] thin it's not like a
king and a queen would sit here it's a
[__] chair that they got for 15
because they needed to get 25 of them
right
they got it at like you know surgery
surgeryemporium.com
and uh they got a deal on them and i'm
just kicking it dude and i'm the only
one there i'm the only one there now
there's no there maybe one other person
in the room waiting
and this lady comes out and
she's a hundred
okay
as in years old she's a hundred
all right she's a little bit more
beautiful then but looks like the crypt
keeper she's
a hundred all right dressed in gucci
because we're in beverly hills
however
she's a year older than 99. she looks
so close do you know what i'm talking
about
now i wish the best for you
but you're so close
okay
i hope things work out for you for as
long as you want but
you're so close
you're knocking
and here i am just being a spry [__]
praying mantis just chilling it
right and i'm chilling it hard just
it's not like i'm aggressively putting
my foot on the arm chair it's like i
my leg
happens to be draped over this [__]
thing okay
and this lady comes in and she's one of
those 100 year old that's like hey hey
how you doing hey hey like one of these
one of those people that you
see coming from a mile away and you
think oh dude i want to be like that
when i'm that age but then very quickly
turn it in your mind to oh i bet that
person makes other people's lives a
living hell
right like people that they actually
know
so
she says you know i gotta tell you to
the people behind the to the people
working there she says
the doctors here are a one they're just
so great and i'm like wow what a nice
lady who the [__] walks to the front and
compliments doctors
and they're like oh yeah they are the
best aren't they and she says every time
i come here it's such a pleasant
experience and then the ladies behind
the counter say well yeah you know she
says okay well i'll see you another oh
she says um she says uh the doctors are
just great and then she says you on the
other hand and they start laughing they
all start laughing and they're joking
and i'm like not only is this lady nice
she's got humor dude
she's a hundred she's knocking she's so
close but she's also keeping it
sarcastic
this is great
so maybe i was wrong about her making
people's lives a living hell and you
know me just sitting down being a
[__] belly up praying mantis
then she looks over at me
and she's looking too long
and i feel it
i don't look at her but i feel it you
know
and then she says
to the ladies behind the counter
this gentleman has his feet on the
furniture
and that's when my
that's what my blood does to something
different doesn't it
it was a certain temperature but now
what's it doing
it's bubbling
but you know what maybe she's riding
that sarcasm that sarcasm wave right
maybe that's what she's doing so she
says this gentleman has his foot on the
table and they laugh
and i laugh
and i look at her and i say well i can
take it down if you'd like and she said
i think it would be a good idea if you
took your feet off the furniture
so now we're politicians that want
something different right
that's like the kind of thing we are
like you have to still meet with
lobbyists but we want something
different but we're cordial and we're
smiling but we're not happy because we
want something different
and i'm furious
so this is what i did i said okay
and left my foot there the whole time
i did it dude
whoa i don't know what's winning or
losing in that situation but i told her
i would do it and then didn't and she
didn't [__] say [__] after that dude
i bothers me when people are just like
like let me live dude
like what what do you
this was a patient dude i told it to
kristen and she was like don't be mean
and then she found out later when i was
talking about it it was a patient she
was like she didn't even work there and
i was like yes exactly if you work there
that's one thing then i get it it's
annoying but okay hey look it's your
place your rules this [__] chick was
getting some surgery done
she was in her pre-op too i think you
need your feet off the man [__] mind
your own business dude you're so close
be happy let people live
dude i don't understand the people that
don't let people live i don't understand
it
this is the guy that i am now obsessed
with and
he is a guy and uh i'm gonna
i'm going to i hope he gets famous
because he's not he's got like 2 000
followers
um
and
he is
will uh
bl william
blunt blunderfield will blunderfield
okay you know will blunderfield is his
name
and he
is a guy that has a lot of
interesting things to say wait here it
is i'm following him
and
here's one of them right here
what is up yogi so people say how do you
use your anal plug in a ritualistic
spiritual context simplest way is
conscious connected breathing aka breath
work
with your anal plug in just lie on the
ground and
breathe so that your perineum your anus
your sex organ your low belly bulges
most people are disconnected from their
roots so just conscious
passive exhale just lie on the ground
just close your eyes put on some nice
music or check out uh robin clements or
edward dangerfield you know
breath masters is really good too brian
carew has some amazing breath work
basically just lie on the ground plays
amusing breathe with the plug-in
and i actually have a breath work
teacher he'd lift up our legs and he'd
stick his perineum in our his stick his
knee in our perineum to help anchor us
as men during breath work we called him
jesus christ
you can do this by yourself just with a
shock reps plug use my code wild naked
man
where's code
we use my code wild naked man dude un
[__] real dude this is not the best
one this is the one that um
one fire sent
uh not the best one so one fire but this
one there are some such good ones dude i
mean where's let's see here
a lot of men have this desire to
showcase their [__] to each other for
example in the locker room but they have
this fear that if they do that and
embrace that proclivity fully that it
might mean that they're gay or that
they're less than the ideal man
but the spartans did that yeah
japan period did that
certain times in ancient india they did
that
first nations tribes they did that
pretty much everywhere before the matrix
took over did that in terms of an alpha
male behavior so why are you feeling
shame about it the only reason why you
feel shame about same-sex erotic bonding
and [__] appreciation rituals is because
the cult that runs this planet
words that are like legit say penis
instead of [__]
oh man dude
there's one
here there's there's one that was just
flipped me out
hold on this guy is unbelievable
the owner of harmonic vancouver
so i believe in my body no no it's not
that one wait come on dude just
so when i retain my seed which i do most
of the time i check maybe once or twice
a month on average sometimes i go for
i notice a direct correlation to how
much also when i flip my body with super
food same thing happens the combination
of sex kung fu detoxification super
foods and semen retention can really
ramp up your ability to be abundant in
every sense of the word so i've got an
amazing business opportunity oh no [__]
dude message and
i've gotten an agent get stressed they
tend to go into a parasympathetic
ejaculatory
addiction
proclivity where they think that if they
have a quick little [__] sneeze yeah you
go into pornhub and watch some
some smut on there that it's gonna like
make them feel better in the long run
but the truth is it takes the body so
much energy to create semen like way
more than even blood so if you're
ejaculating when you get stressed you're
actually lowering your ability to handle
the stress and to come back into the
hormesis
jesus
[Applause]
and to come back into the hernia
says
this guy is unbelievable and you're
welcome dude will blunderfield episode
hold on
a lot of people want to know about my
take on womanhood and women's rituals
now while i'm at this one you know i
don't lead that many i have actually led
a bunch of naked women's uh naked
awakenings and naked yoga classes where
it's just me and a bunch of nude women
it's been gorgeous i really really felt
honored doing that um but yeah i guess
my take on it is i really really believe
in yoni steaming rituals and
clitoral and vaginal massage
rituals in a circle so basically all the
women are naked they brew some beautiful
herb
steaming teas and a big vat and then
they basically put it underneath their
yoni's aka their vaginas and they sit in
a circle and they basically steam their
vaginas together it's very very
beautiful uh women would do this in
asian cultures well the shaman dude
would lead the alpha males through
erotic bonding rituals so yang would be
sharpening yang and yin would be
sharpening yin is a very beautiful
experience so that's kind of to my two
cents also putting the jade egg you can
use my i mean what is up yogis
so you gotta have
[Applause]
what was the one where he was talking
about just [__]
playing with his dude's [__]
anything that sharpens young energy hold
on so we're going to do a little
unboxing now you guys got to hear this
one sorry what's up it's a little hack
if you've you know have a little bit of
indigestion no no no no no no
i remember i was probably like 12 years
old that's going
um
all right so here it is dude i found it
we have to cut to find it but dude this
is the one man this is the one that is
just the most greatest one so i had an
amazing organ me dinner with my bro
morgan meet them we got naked and we
just chilled in my bed and watched some
obi-wan kenobi
and we basically just held each other's
mushrooms
and kind of just like massaged the heart
meridian because in chinese medicine at
least in classical chinese medicine
penis is the outermost extension of the
heart especially that heart meridian
let's see if i can
show this to you right here heart
meridian
this is a diagram in terms of penis
reflexology it's a little bit blurry but
you can basically see there's all like
the pineal gland is right before the
urethra
the heart is all about the fire element
it's the small intestine as well stores
self-hatred cruelty and impatience so
basically we massage each other's heart
meridians to help release self-hatred
while cuddling and watching obi-wan
kenobi
they would also suck each other's
nipples and share each other's beds
before battle ah
threw that last one in there they'd also
suck each other's nipples and share each
other's beds for before battle our
celtic ancestors dude anytime someone
anyone brings up celtic ancestors
they're gone bro they're gone
cuddled in bed with a guy and rubbed
each other's mushroom meridians
robbed each other's mushroom meridians
and watched the new obi-wan kenobi on
disney plus
hey guy
and that's okay
but if you're rubbing the heart
merinians if you're rubbing the
outermost area of the heart of the heart
according to ancient china
you're gay
and that's all right but also let me go
one further if you're watching obi-wan
kenobi you're gay
star wars [__] is over
it stopped
after jar jar binks
we were done
okay
like marvel movies okay
they made moon night
bye bye
basically it's just disney plus is
ruining everything
okay the guy
cuddled in bed
and rubbed it's amazing and you know
this guy goes now by the way i like this
guy so you can follow him but don't
[__] make fun of him i'll do that
go follow him if you're interested in
rubbing [__] with another guy in a
non-gay way only because your celtic
ancestors did it okay i think it's a
beautiful thing it stores energy and if
you're splurting too much then you get
more stressed out is what he's saying
but anyway i'm gonna take his class
dude he's got so many classes and he's
got codes that you can um
that you can you can pay for i'm gonna
pay for his [__] i should go
dude this guy's incredible a lot of
breath work with this [__] anal
plug-in
wow hey you know what anyone happy good
on you man this is cool
i like this guy but it's incredible
and that's being caused largely by
atrazine and glyphosate and it's it's
not that there's anything unnatural
about same-sex erotic bonding but what's
happening is
our psyches know that our procreative
urge is being dampened down and that
sucks there's nothing more juicy than
being a virile stag-like minotaur man
who can you know please women and ravish
the ladies
so when that feeling comes back in full
force through superfood nutrition sex
kung fu and detox
as well as transmutation and scene
retention you just human retention and
then the gay panic goes away right
there's nothing wrong with same-sex
bonding but there's something very wrong
about having your sex desire to
procreate be pinched off
by chemicals that they put in the food
in the pharmaceuticals so
only uh onlyfans.com
[Laughter]
head on over to onlyfans.com dude and
watch me [__] sit on my anal plug and
breathe
anyway not gay dude the guys get the
hottest chick i'm not [__] around
this is pictures of him with the hottest
chick it's unbelievable dude
bro what the [__] this world's crazy
dude imagine like somebody from 1940
that like was like already gonna like a
60 year old from 1940 just all of a
sudden being alive today they'd be like
what about anything they'd be like what
dude holy [__] man
so anyway it's not gay to
[__] a guy and that sucks that people
fear it's gay and i'm not gay anyway uh
send uh go over to my only fans if
you're a guy especially
and let's not be gay together
ejaculation ritual you know semen
retention
[__] semen retention
um
i don't uh
i don't understand this
i mean i i
this is the thing about roe versus wade
since we're talking about it
first of all the outrage of everything
is always so annoying no matter what i
don't care i don't care if they're
beheading
white people just chill
everybody online you're not doing
anything okay
obviously because guess what happened it
got overturned so it's not working what
you're doing and um it's so annoying
that people think that they can just
scream and make it better and you can't
you just can't okay cops still killing
people uh unjustly and also uh there are
great cops out there and you're not
gonna change just by screaming okay and
also
they overturn roe versus wade but um i
don't like what people say roe v wade
just save versus you know you're making
it shorter okay but
[__] at least give it some respect
so
um
you know
the protests i saw downtown
um
i mean nancy pelosi wrote read a poem in
reaction to overturning roe vs wade so
that's too much don't write don't ever
you know what's done poetry yep and i
know people that are my friends that
would be mad at me for saying it but
poetry dude we have like vr headsets now
you know so um
times move on and poetry's done but
there's i'm looking at this one guy who
had a sign who made you the coochie boss
okay
and then this one by doug ducey i am
proud that uh he's a um what do you call
it a [__] political dude i am proud
that arizona has been ranked the most
pro-life state in the country here we
will continue to cherish life and
protect it in every way possible and
then some chick wrote your son made me
take plan b after we hooked up but carry
carry-on
so much wrong with the world um i wonder
if that's true or not dude that's
gangster for her to tweet that um yeah
you know i just it's so weird and i
here's the thing i know the supreme
court what was it five to four or i
don't know what the [__] it was
six to three like i know that the like
those people said most of them believe
pro-life and [__] uh but people got
stuff on them you know what i mean like
everyone's being blackmailed at the top
there's no [__] way that that people
aren't being blackmailed at the top
that's how you get to the top blackmail
you know
you you have blackmail on people or you
blackmail people at the top tippy top
i'm talking about dude
um
like there's p tapes with donald trump
people got [__] on bill clinton whatever
the [__] it is uh
and um
and so
[__]
this thing is what they believe uh six
versus three but if you talk to anybody
else that's not them most of the people
are gonna say people should be able to
do what they want also when it comes to
themselves they should be able to do
what they want and they know that
so
you know this is going to have a huge
effect on america obviously because
there's going to be people that are born
it's going to [__] up the system they're
going to have the unwanted babies and
those unwanted babies that grow up the
people who voted for the pro-life
they're not going to give a [__] about
them at that point because that's how it
goes now i am a [__]
staunch republican but i will say
i will say
that dude because you know you pushed
your boy on over right you pushed me on
over
all right so i am a
staunch republican dude
i don't even know what staunch means but
i heard it and i will tell you dude
i i you know
this is crazy dude people are just gonna
drive now more people are gonna drive to
california to try and get abortions
could be more people in california more
mattresses are gonna be on fire in the
middle of the street it could be so
[__] annoying dude
now because [__] you know what's it
gonna be arizona and
utah they're gonna be [__]
nope you gotta have it someone raped you
doesn't matter still gotta have a baby
incest doesn't matter still gotta have
that baby it's gonna come out all lumpy
doesn't matter and have it come out and
then we won't give off a [__] about it
how about that
or they're just gonna be driving a
[__] california or wherever the [__]
i don't know what states are doing it or
what but they say the slippery slope
argument and that's a real thing dude
that's a real thing whether you want to
believe it or not but it's a slippery
slope pretty soon we're going to be in
the handmaid's tale and i'm going to be
that dude that's like yeah okay well
i'm going to be ray finds in it
i stopped watching the handmaid's tale
it was too dramatic have some jokes in
it dude
i just think that this [__]
i'm kind of scared for people you know
i'm scared for for women that they don't
want to have
it's just i don't know man
pop star pink demands pro-life americans
never [__] listen to my music again
not how it works the most not how it
works thing dude you know
and then a guy named gunther tweeted it
and said okay
if your name gum if you're gunther
you're pro you're not you're pro-life
dude if you're my if you're my fan
listen to my
stand up whether or not you voted either
way or what you want i don't care even
clarence [__] what's his name i want
you at my shows
clarence atomic claire i would want to
say clarence clemons the [__] guy who
played the sax in the [__] e street
band
um
my dad would always talk about how much
he liked clarence clemons
then he died
um not my dad
um
what's his deserved scale
oh my god
oh it's removed
is it no here it is
wow dude
the music
oh that's titanic dude
how many people are here 50 are in a
[__] monster truck with a
[__]
crate on it look at these idiots driving
look it's called monstro world gonna
sink good dude
wow
gonna i mean do they they don't they do
know that it's happening right now right
they do know that they're [__]
i mean
oh my god the driver dude is sinking
it just keeps moving forward and sinking
oh trying to get out here we go another
one backwards wow people died oh my god
dude imagine your [__] mom is in
there oh my god
wow dude
horrible
swimming wow look at these [__] to
deserve it and we're back sorry i had to
go to the bathroom getting older you
know gotta sometimes go to the bathroom
um
[Music]
whoops whoops whoops
but i did i did not expect to find a
fence like this here
this was sent by one of the discord
people um from love sponge on our
patreon on the discord sign up for our
patreon
send in some stuff
like this dude
woman physically attracted to offense i
like so much these angles fabulous
fabulous
feeling the fence like it's a [__]
weird man how much has this girl been
hurt by men you know
that she finds a fence attractive
sitting on the fence fences are such
dangerous objects for me well when
you're sitting on them like that because
they are so perfect wow
and their geometry
i mean sitting on it
sitting here and i have to say there is
a lot of physical stuff going on right
now yeah no [__] man i mean anything it
[__] will make you feel good if you
rub it on your genitals dude
oh i love baseball cards just [__]
got a [__] ken griffey jr on your
[__] oh i love baseball cars just
wetting up wade boggs
wetting up a [__] the third baseman
from the from the red sox oh yeah
baseball cards are so hot
[Laughter]
just [__] rubbing a hensley mulens on
your [__] oh yeah i love baseball cards
[__] sticking a john already up your
[__] oh [__] yeah love that a die-cut
[__] david cone
got a die-cut got an embossed die-cut
david cone flicking your bean oh love i
love baseball cards
got a [__]
j bunner got a fleer ultra j bunner
stuck in your anus oh baseball cards are
amazing as you're [__] all over a
[__]
howard johnson [__]
upper deck die cut
fully embossed
[__] you know
oh i don't know why i'm so attracted to
baseball cards said the man jacking off
on a [__]
frank thomas slugging percentage [__]
and i think that happens between human
relationships as well oh you think i'm
definitely physically attracted to this
fence um and i would like to get to know
this fence better can't can't
can't
it's a fence
dude i'd love to get this i'd love to
take this fence to dinner
how many two please uh
just be on my fence
you are sweet wow dirty talking with the
fence
wow
it's it's not sweet you know it's not
sweet you know why it's not sweet
because it's only a fence
only sweet in the sense that it's like
[__] oh [__] that's sweet bro that
was it for youtube if you want to catch
the uncut episode the longer episode the
extra-long episode going over to
patreon.com
also once a month we have an extra
episode on our patreon we also do
another segment called review mode which
is a whole separate thing that we record
uh where our review [__] um and it's a
rip roaring good time dude
patreon.comcrystalia sign on up for just
six bucks a month you get all that extra
stuff thanks
[Music]
oops
all right
here's what we do
here's how we do it